do have a look around the area
will do
group of the valentinos led by zoe
alonso at large
her record includes armed robbery
extortion kidnapping
and first-degree murder night city
authorities offering a reward for
neutralizing alonzo's criminal network
[Music]
so
yep
no way
[Music]
do have a look around the area i lost
contact with the de la main network
vehicle nearby
will do
is
looks like someone [ __ ] calm
have you come to finish me off no
just here to reset you
guess i'll have to do it myself though
whoa easy easy
i'm not out to hurt you but i am
there are other ways out beside suicide
what
therapy a colossal waste of time
shrinks hate vehicles we don't have
mothers
could go back into the fold rejoin the
network
you know one big happy family
delaman detests me
listen from suicide ain't no coming back
it's always worth looking for a better
way you patronize me because i'm a car
i'm not like you hey my body's just a
body
you exist you think the world gets you
down
don't see how we're any different
so you'd offer this advice to a human in
my place gotta try to come to terms with
this thing called life dell
one wheel revolution at a time
fine i'll go back
control of the vehicle restored and i
thank you
you ought to show this one some love
just saying
apologies i simply don't understand and
fear i've no time to ask
other more urgent tasks require my
attention
you're an absent father that's what i
mean
i see penny a share of your fee has been
transferred
you